in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape with me in the
studio today is dr. / Reuters specialist
on pain management from the shiit here
in billion hello and welcome to the show
dr. Hoyt nearly everybody has taken some
painkillers in their life for smaller
pain or acute pain but when a painkiller
simply not enough pain a killer
painkillers and not enough when they
don't take away the pain when patients
have to increase the number of tablets
to get rid of the pain and when the pain
recurs and becomes a chronic daily pain
that can even be some kind of adverse
effects like the painkillers intensify
the pain by themselves yes that's
possible that's what I was talking about
if you need to increase the number of
tablets to get pain relief then there's
the chance that everything reverts and
the painkillers can cause pain at some
point and the solution is just simply
get discontinued the painkillers what's
the solution for that that's one
probable solution but there are other
solutions which are multi modular
treatment of the pain ok so there's
acute pain and there's something like
chronic pain so what does a specialist
say when does pain become chronic pain
becomes chronic when it persists for
more than three months more than three
months then you say it's a chronic pain
and sometimes the cause of the pain is
vanished like an slip this the disc step
back but the pain is still there how can
I say come to this we have a pain memory
you can learn pain pain like you learn
how to calculate in school and as soon
as our brain knows as soon as the nerve
cell cells have learned then it's much
easier for them to generate pain so
there's no cause at all but this pain is
going on going on and the treatment for
that pills no not only pills pills are
one consistent element or one less
three elements for treatment but other
treatments like psychological treatment
seeing a psychiatrist and other
treatments are very helpful as we saw in
the report from the multi modular pain
management thing they are different
specialties working together and so why
is this necessary that different doctors
work together pain is not a single
disorder pain associated with many other
disorders like anxiety or depression and
pain is also very much dependent on
emotions so you need a specialist on
emotions that psychologists to see and
to analyze all other disorders that help
to contribute to generate pain and the
psychologist does he just helped the
patient in coping with the pain to gain
coping strategies or does the
psychologist really reduce the level of
the pain psychologists help to cope but
moreover they have to analyze the
courses for pain and by doing so also to
reduce the pain in my office I sometimes
see patients who get depressed when they
in constant pain and chronic pain but
sometimes depressed patient are getting
pain so the depression can cause pain
and the pain can cause depression is
like a vicious circle and how can you
distinguish what comes first very often
you cannot distinguish what comes first
we know that depression can cause pain
and pain can also cause depression we
know from neuroimaging studies that
paint and this depression both activate
the same structures in the brain and if
I got a patient with a depression and
the pain he's sure candidate for the
multimodal pain management definitely
okay no dork and the patient expect from
this approach the patient no patients
usually do not become pain free and that
patients can expect a significant
reduction in more than thirty percent
reduction of pain intensity and
frequency many patients worldwide suffer
from chronic headache or migraine what
can you expect from medication therapy
acute medication therapy is usually not
very helpful in chronic headaches in
chronic headaches you need preventive
therapy and the preventatives we use are
antidepressants anti-epileptic or other
substance classes on migrants like beta
blockers that just
get rid of all those migraine attacks
that's fully was it easier to treat
headaches preventively like a big becca
back pain yes it's easier to treat
headaches preventively okay doctor
sometimes prescribed medication which
are not painkillers but and dissociate
the patient from the pain what do
doctors mean by dissociation from pain
that's a very common approach and what
the drugs do is they lay a cloud around
the pain centers in the brain and
protect the pain centers in the brain
from generating new pain and what kind
of patients but we would you prescribe
those kind of pills in patients with
chronic headaches meaning patients with
more than 10 days headaches per month
and patients can't get addicted to them
no from these painters distancing drugs
you cannot get dependent what else would
you advise patients with chronic pain
just apart from painkillers and those
dissociation drugs it's absolutely
necessary in addition to painkillers or
preventive drugs to do psycho set up
psychological treatment treatments like
muscle relaxation or autogenic training
or acupuncture for example because I can
puncture help in chronic pain
acupuncture helps in chronic
tension-type headache but in chronic
migraine acupuncture is as good as sham
acupuncture meaning when you freak the
needles not in the acupuncture
acupuncture spots but in spots next to
them that's surprising isn't it yeah
it's a bit surprising can you just
ignore chronic pain like say okay I will
just continue with my life I don't think
about the pain does it get worse or does
it get better no you should not ignore a
chronic pain it stupidly getting worse
then you need to master disciplinary
approach to treat chronic pain okay we
had a lot of your questions from all
over the world I think pain is a global
phenomenon so let me just ask you some
questions of our viewers milta friend
Alou from thailand and she's got a
migraine and the migraine doesn't get
better from pills what should not to do
so difficult question to answer from the
distance but we need to know whether
acute pain doesn't disappear or whether
she just got chronic pain how many
tablets she takes per day or per month
maybe
medication overuse headaches because she
takes tablets on a daily base so this is
one of those things where you could just
try to discontinue the medication and
see if it gets better gets better yes
okay you got a question from the Lebanon
Medea abita Maloof from Lebanon her
child has headaches after coming home
from school do you think about that
headaches and children is more common
than we usually think we need to check
out whether this school day is too
stressful for the for the child where
the child has enough time to play in
between classes we need to analyze this
and then there's probably a solution for
the child and sometimes some some visual
problems might have might lead to
headaches as well so they just need
glasses yes that's also very calm common
in very young children it was kind of a
tension headache then or yeah it's more
attention here again ok and let's go to
back pain yichang from china wants to
know what's the best exercise training
for a back thing it's probably a muscle
relaxation therapy jakub method or
autogenic training okay Alex Java can t
Martines from Brazil dislocated his
shoulder in a traffic accident and he
still has a painful shoulder shoulder
after weeks especially at night and his
GP wants to prescribe steroids now this
is the right approach steroids helped to
relieve pain but you shouldn't take
steroids for longer than two or three
weeks because of adverse events okay
esta and risen from New Zealand has head
and neck pain after work so what kind of
relaxation technique is the best
difficult to answer again muscle
relaxation Jacobson's method autogenic
raining of the water thanks so much for
being in the studio thank you look
you